we're back now here on CBS mornings and
Alec murdaugh will be sentenced today
after his Speedy conviction in South
Carolina the once prominent lawyer was
found guilty of murdering his wife and
son back in June of 2021 it's a trial
that lasted six weeks but the jury
returned its verdict yesterday after
deliberating for less than three hours
Murdoch now faces 30 years to life in
prison CBS News legal analyst Ricky
cleeman joins us now Ricky good morning
to you I looked it up 75 plus Witnesses
800 exhibits reports uh photographs and
yet the jury took less than three hours
to reach its decision what did you think
when that happened
well I thought the timing was either
shocking actually it was one thing for
them to come to a rather quick decision
meaning a day or two if they were going
to find Alec Murdoch guilty it's another
thing to come to the decision within
three hours so there's only one logical
way Tony that that happened and that was
that instead of a four-person deciding
to go through every piece of evidence
which many four people will do that they
really decided to look at a couple of
pieces of evidence and I would bet my
house that what they really discussed
were the lies of Alec murder and his
testimony which is always the risk of
putting a defendant on the witness stand
yeah prosecutors told us in the last
half hour Ricky that it clearly was a
mistake for him to take the stand but
did he really have a choice after that
video show that he was at the scene when
he had said that he wasn't at the scene
well it's always a problem Gail when
you're faced with this Hobson's choice
and only the defendant has the right to
make that decision we do not know if
this was the lawyer's advice that he
should testify or if he disregarded the
lawyer's advice and said I am going to
testify because I am the only person who
can save myself
you may recall that I said his direct
examination at the time was compelling
but one of the things we learn in trial
of cases is that the great engine of
Truth is cross-examination and he was
put in a position which he knew he would
be put in of being faced with every
single lie with all of the cheating with
the embezzlement showing that there was
not one person who really knew who he
was so did he have a choice well the
lawyers could have argued which many
criminal defense lawyers do that this
was a case based on reasonable doubt if
they did not offer him up and Reasonable
Doubt is a great thing for defense
lawyers to argue
so Ricky there was another sort of
remarkable moment the judge denied the
defense's motion for a mistrial saying
that the evidence of guilt is
overwhelming the judge's words does the
defense have grounds for an appeal
the defense may have grounds for an
appeal on a variety of legal issues but
this was also a case that was very very
well tried on both sides one of the
things that happens which may be bad for
an appeal is when you have defense
attorneys who are as talented as these
two he's certainly Alec murder certainly
got his money's worth with these two
lawyers they really gave it their all
and when the judge denied the motion for
a judgment of acquittal or a motion for
mistrial which is really saying
in spite of the jury's verdict judge you
should really decide that this person is
not guilty the judge had the perfect
right at that point because the jury had
spoken to make the comment that the
evidence was overwhelming and in that
situation that affects a judge's mind
when he is going to sentence
all right we'll be watching later today
Ricky Clement always great to have you
thank you very much